I love that you write a book and you get
to like go all over New Zealand right
like for this book yeah right yeah I
went to New Zealand um traveled all over
the islands and uh it's it's kind of
like Peter Pan's World honestly the it's
got Alpine it's got glaciers it's got
amazing mountains FS jungle flightless
birds great white sharks there's so much
to do there it really is an incredible
place it's beautiful I remember the
first time I went there I was like why
do I not live here right parts of it
remind me of Scotland it's got a real
Scottish connection that's kind of the
reason I went there but um it is
mountainous it's it's an epic epic
country and you are the person that goes
to I'm the person that goes to a place
and like enjoys the scenery and you're a
person that Adventures around right you
do all the things that might kill you
yeah yeah yeah yeah I I dived with great
white sharks I jumped off cliffs they
have obviously they invented bungee
jumping in New Zealand they invented
zorbing if you don't know what that is
it's it's a big ball that you climb
inside and then roll down a
hill it sounds terrible it was great fun
if it fil worst ride at a fair is what
it sounds like pretty you then could
fill the bowl with water or Jin maybe or
whatever you want now you've reeled me
in okay all right well I heard that the
the forward is Peter Jackson that's
amazing Lord of the Rings did you meet
while you were there like sure Peter
Jackson no we didn't meet him
unfortunately but um you my co-star
graah he had worked on The Hobbit many
years ago I was possibly named after a
hobbit my brother was named after an elf
in real life um so I was like this is
meant to be so we went to WETA where
they build all of the the animatronics
and the athetics and they actually made
me up to be a creature from L of rings
in The Hobbit unfortunately it wasn't an
elf it was a dwarf I I got to play groin
groin the dwarf okay and uh it was quite
a transformation I know wait I want to
see the picture because it's it it is
quite the transformation there he is yes
that guy is not picking up a lot of
women in New
York I don't know guy I mean well maybe
a particular
kind
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home